[Music]
even forgiving the nine seconds of black
screen this logo takes up 34 seconds for
one goddamn studio Thanos supposedly
kills half of a people he encounters so
is this half of what was left of Asgard
because it looks like a whole lot more
I'm also wondering since Asgard lost so
many at the hands of Cate Blanchett and
thorne part three does famous update
what constitutes 50% population of a
planet or should we give him a pass
since he couldn't possibly know the
devastation Asgard just went through the
tesseract your brother's head this
two-hour and 30-minute incomplete movie
where Thanos locates all the Infinity
stones is only necessary so the Thanos
can snap half the universe's population
to death just so he can be lazy all this
trouble he's going through to find
Infinity stones he could have travelled
planet to planet and did this job faster
like six years ago when we were
introduced to him in the first Avengers
we don't destroy as God if Thor doesn't
send Loki down into Odin's trophy room
at the end of Thor the third does the
tesseract survive it and float around in
space and to stano's quest and when he
realizes he can't possess the space
stone that's the snap only produce
impotent sparks at that point it's a
hypothetical I grant but I'm sending it
anyway we have a hawk why does Hulk hold
back during the battle while fanless
destroys the Asgardian ship until the
end when Loki says we have a Hulk was he
doing before then
Thanos destroys Hulk with only one stone
in his glove later with many stones in
the glove his punch will be held by
super angry Captain America after coming
to a tow with Iron Man on Titan for a
good bit and the Power Distribution
slash comparisons and the MCU have never
felt more squirrelly than in this movie
also
where's Valkyrie Valkyrie should have at
least been shouted out in this movie
thank ed and Valkyrie got half my people
the way to safety is all Thor had to say
later just who the fuck is this guy
we've sat through 18 goddamn films and
if I'm remembering correctly 75% of the
MCU has been Thanos bitching about
traffic on the freeway and we haven't
once been introduced to these powerful
fucks the farm around or why he needs to
fine than my two
bring them to me on time sure put
infinity stone or evil in the hands of
your henchmen that worked so well in the
39 other movies didn't you literally
grumble fine I'll do it myself
Oh No Loki's gonna die again like in
Thor the dark world which definitely
means he's probably not dead and even if
he is I'm sending it anyway because that
dark world scene did not get sinned
enough in previous movies we were told
Hulk and Banner have different memories
so how does Banner remembers the Hulk
alone knows Tony Stark famous Avengers
running around Central Park and nobody's
bothering him this guy is more famous
than any president or celebrity in
history Tony Stark
to normal people see this while I know
New Yorkers are up on their Avengers
knowledge I'm not quite so sure they've
been informed about the Masters of the
mystic arts its banks and 6 elemental
crystals hurtling across the virgin
universe if the universe is infinite
we're at least close to it then these
stones were sent directions that should
have guaranteed no one could ever
combine them all just based on sheer
math also why six two weeks ago vision
turn off his transponder he's offline
okay if he had a transponder and knew it
he wouldn't have waited until two weeks
ago to turn it off so this is some both
we both can't run fell out hard we're
not on speaking terms are youing what
was that letter caps hit you at the end
of civil war then he specifically said
if you need me I'll be there all these
dudes are superheroes and they all sense
something sinister is happening outside
but instead of instantly leaping into
battle they take several seconds to gape
like children at the strange noise like
dickheads
the alien ship causes Peter spidey sense
to go off and homecoming didn't give us
any indication spidey sense even existed
and now this movie is just thrusting an
army alike well almost like they forgot
it was a thing and are only now
implementing it stretchy Ned you are a
treasure maybe none of the classmates on
the bus see Peter do this plenty of
other drivers and passengers on this
bridge do and in the age of smartphones
and dash cams and government
surveillance this transition was
definitely seen and captured on film and
Peter's cover's blown forever the matter
with you kids yeah sure
they've seen a spaceship and it usually
means bad things I've seen a tornado
before that doesn't mean that when it
happens I'm gonna sit on the bus reading
Madame Bovary bring me the stone dude a
minute ago you were making metal fly
with a flick of your wrist why do you
even need the futuristic space ax do to
do this for you
versus hope transformation troubles
become an impotence metaphor and does
that mean when he's successful it's like
he's a huge green boner and what does
that say about his character that he can
only become erect when he's angry this
is the most embarrassing Mark Ruffalo's
been since in the cup I realized that
nanobots are legit real-world science to
a degree but Tony suit is applying it in
ways that make it utterly unbelievable
here's some we definitely won't use
later when it could sway the fate of the
universe I mean there are much more
important dangerous hands that this
could be used for to cut off in this
film unlock 17a thank God
Stark had pre designed and built and
voice programmed for deployment a space
worthy iron spider-man suit in the I'm
guessing a few months and spider-man
homecoming Friday why didn't the suit
just fly him back to wherever Tony
wanted him to go you're telling me that
the suit doesn't fly then why doesn't it
if the suit does fly then there's no
need for the parachute send-off
especially if you've got Friday
controlling it somehow after that
massive battle that ended in that one
park banner retraced his steps and found
Tony's phone in the rubble like a needle
in a haystack calls and thinks you're
making this too difficult well this is
100% definitely not a reaction to
cinemasins complaining about Tex place
names and movies being used when they're
unnecessary
this is 100% definitely not a reaction
to cinemasins complaining about Tex
place names and movies being used when
they are necessary of all the retro
references to make Groot is playing
defender looking and fury ating video
game why is even playing ancient earth
games anyway aren't there are modern
alien games to download from the nebula
that though is convenient illogical but
I do love Fig Newtons after that
encounter with a sudden new alien being
Groot is still playing handheld video
games there comes a point when a
parent's got a parent and clearly no one
aboard this ship ever did that
so Groot ends up like that affluenza kid
in Texas and everyone around him acts
like oh snap he's such a bad seed why
didn't anyone do anything he's anxious
angry he feels tremendous loss and guilt
so basically every single American then
or even every human are we all anxious
angry and feeling lost these days
mantises empath revelations are more
obvious than Forest Whitaker's and
species are you guys that's an awfully
rude way to greet people you don't know
I once woke up in this room and this
dude tried to do all this gnarly to me
with these strange tools and I was like
who the hell are you and he said I'm
your fucking dentist asshole dr. James
Packer DDS was tough but fair
retrieves another stone he'll be too
powerful to stop he already is how
exactly did they expect to stop Thanos
who doesn't even need Infinity stones to
be powerful but already has two of the
plus Thanos needs Gamora to get the soul
stone keep and Gamora away from Thanos
as strategy 101 but because there's no
time they hastily conjure up some no ass
plan vision and wand are supposedly on
the run and hiding out from I guess the
government but this apartment or hotel
room is largest this looks like a
honeymoon not a couple on the lam
Romancing the Stone also they went from
kind of maybe flirty - kissy face hotel
buddies and deeply in love entirely
off-screen look this is the fucking MCU
I refuse to believe anything is an
accident and I'm losing sleep trying to
unravel the meaning of we will deep-fry
your kebab is it a promise a threat
guarantee a cipher key the sign is
taking up way more screen space than
Wanda's face it has to mean something
did that alien assassins sneak up on an
Android without being heard or seen or
sensed the plenty stop it's literally
the only explanation this movie's gonna
give for why the two most powerful
Avengers end up needing help from some
punchy fools like Black Widow and no
longer Captain America Wanda is hand to
handing this henchman she's a magic
witch that fooled all the minds the
Avengers with false visions of awful
futures at once why does she have to
throw her mind powers at people
why did cap need to make a dramatic
entrance into this scene and why on the
other side of the tracks why isn't he
helping already and in the time it took
both Scarlet Witch and prxima to figure
out who it was either of them could have
potentially won the fight while the
other was distracted audience applause
break guns these henchmen failed to get
the stone they were sent after and they
piece out to save their own skin and I'm
pretty sure even they know that Thanos
values the stones over his henchmen so
look at these minions thinking bailing
out like this
stay close check in don't take any
chances
you just wanted time you know to figure
out the whole having sex with the
synthetic vibranium body think it's a
lot tougher than you'd think
I hope the analyst is keeping count
during all this disorder and chaos
because I can't figure out how many are
dying at first glance but I'm sure he
knows how to keep the death at half C's
this room the fact that Thanos would
ever have stopped on his kill quest for
even a moment because of a cute kid is a
big pill to swallow you grade the
fighter girl she asked a question that's
it
she's displayed zero fighter
characteristics she's inquisitive
confused scared guileless but a fighter
she is not this half genocide scene
illustrates a curious character detail
in guardians of the galaxy when they
told us Gamora was the only survivor
Santos gets me I want you to promise me
don't kill me
one other thing you could do just find a
distant planet to live on lay low find a
cave maybe find Spock and don't allow
Thanos to ever get near you you mother
Looby characters think that a promise
will be a bond if they swear on a loved
one but of course it doesn't work that
way cliche I realize she has a hate
boner of justice but goddamn what was
she thinking she's the one that's been
reminding others how powerful Thanos is
pretty mature herself reprobation you
knew I come I come so he assumed that
the guardianship would get the distress
signal from the Statesman they'd follow
it they just so happen to run into Thor
he'd tell them about the reality stone
and that she would agree to come here
this is being impossibly brilliant he
didn't even tell Thor he'd be coming
here he just told his minions to get the
two stones on earth and meet him at
Titan
the only reason he pulls the trigger
here is because the movie knows it's
going to undo the act and keep Gamora
alive for now his love for her and dopey
puppy-dog nature 100% does not jibe with
his willfully pulling the trigger here
why did Drax and mantis go back to
normal when Thanos leaves the stone
powers aren't proximity-based but
somehow the damage he did was only
temporary this is a hologram of Ross
whose physical body is in a completely
different room somewhere
country and yet he's able to walk around
this room like he's physically in this
one is he in a replica room with a
virtual reality display and if so there
should be a camera somewhere in here
tracking his eye movements so he can
face the right way when he's talking to
people right no one in this movie should
own a Rickenbacker bass and have it
displayed on a floor stand in some kind
of library this guitar is the biggest
lie the MCU ever told I played one of
these tell me congressman have you ever
played a Rickenbacker bass where is it
fine Kentucky are we just gonna gloss
over the fact that a stark shoulder
missile from Earth easily blasts a hole
in the hull of this alien spaceship the
hell is this spray stuff tony's using
here to seal the breach in the ship's
hull nano magic and convenience it's
magic wiz and it's cheesing me off way
to introduce a new character in the
movie in the 19th film of a franchise
and completely kill him off in an hour
Darth Maul and ebony ma are now in some
seventh circle of movie franchise Hell
where they were told they were special
and mole their fates with mole Flanders
at the Hades mall so I say we take the
fight to him granted the ship you're on
is going to him
and you haven't stated declaratively
that you can turn the ship around
despite being asked twice by strange
maybe this is less of a choice than the
movie or Tony wants to make it seem you
planet was on the brink of collapse
I'm the one who stopped that you know
what's happened since then
I don't know has 50% of the planet
multiplied and brought it back to pre
Thanos population numbers I guess you
plan on snapping the universe back to
half its people every 20 years or so
this seems so pointless don't do this
ultimately sisterly love is what causes
her to give up the location of the soul
stone and therefore the fate of the
entire universe she begged her boyfriend
to kill her rather than let fan o's win
getting new hama the word 33 and 1/3
odin told him his hammer was just
something that focused his power now
that's been forgotten and a hammer is
important again you gonna need more than
one stupid I will but you're handing him
a fake eyeball so he still only has one
stupid eyeball right some random
computerized alien eyeball has a
connection port that matches Thor's
flesh based eyes socket connection port
so this is a second Marvel movie to
waste Peter Dinklage did he choose if
you would anyway would accepted me let
me do some math here 300 dwarves were
here one is left carry the 9 multiply by
PI R squared that's ninety nine point
six seven percent of the dwarf
population which means he must have left
299 other dwarves on some other hammer
building station live
that's all well and good but how did she
get out of the mid air suspension thing
that she was in doesn't that thing make
you for all intents and purposes
immobile in fact I'm kind of wondering
how she was even able to kill that guy
wind up implanting eggs in my chest or
something and I eat one of you I'm sorry
I do not want another single pop-culture
reference that even I'm trying to say
that something is coming really because
there was absolutely nothing urgent
about what you were saying at all
in theory could even summon the Bifrost
because why not Thor's gonna have to get
to earth faster than a ship can take
them somehow
so bacon the Bifrost into this baby and
we're set what are the odds a far-flung
planet moon like Titan would have air
breathable by humans so wait at the end
of Captain America Red Skull touches the
space stone and is sent into space to be
a sort of keeper of the soul stone it
really just seems like a reason to
shoehorn Red Skull back into the story
more than anything that makes sense
guiding others to a treasure I cannot
possess are you saying you've had a lot
of people looking for the soul stone
since you got sitting here in 1945 what
happened before you were here its warren
g harding guiding people back then so
holds a special place among the Infinity
stones why you might say it is a certain
wisdom but why stone demands sacrifice
why does the soul stone require so many
more parameters to acquire it than any
other stone it's like the original
creators of the stones themselves said
okay if you're powerful enough to hold
the other five gems will let you change
reality move across space it will
increase your strength and harness the
most powerful energy in the universe go
into the past of the future and access
other people's minds but when it comes
to controlling all life in the universe
that's where we draw the line dude's got
kind of a thing for bubbles I see I feel
like the sacrifice of Gamora would have
played a lot better if Thanos had been
given his own proper origin film and if
we'd had more reason to suspect his love
for her this death is sad until you
realized that a the time stone will end
up figuring into her coming back to life
anyway and be that despite all the
problems since the firing of James Gunn
guardians of the galaxy three was ready
to go into production after this movie
the hell happens here he kills her the
weather gets weird a flash suddenly he's
in a pool of water with a stone how and
where is there any water here anyway
it's like an ice dimension with snow is
he not on for me or anymore I'm actually
so confused by this cut I suspect the
next movie might hinge in some small way
on it but whatever it's still a weird
cut location
in the movie and I shall sin it
something sentencing atmosphere just one
line about how Thanos or something with
the stones tells him exactly where each
one is would be king terrific it didn't
help him at all with the soul stone he
needed Gomorrah to tell him that
so why the precision knowledge with the
others these ships hit the earth at
massive speed I don't understand why
they don't do to the planet with meteors
that large would do like in deep impact
or an age of Ultron and yet they don't
they just caused little fire ripples and
loud noises this battle at Wakanda
doesn't make a whole lot of strategical
sense
Thanos already has enough stones to
wreck these Earthlings on his own he
needs vision stone that's basically the
only reason he sends this army feels
like we needed something action II to do
with a bunch of our characters that
didn't make the trip to Titan and we
came up with this I'm gonna hold it open
that's suicide
so who's facing finals without that axe
okay dude you can had a magical hammer
made by this guy at this place and your
sister smashed it like it was chocolate
I take offense to the idea that I'm axe
from here could defeat Thanos and the
fact that it nearly does these Star Wars
asks Kid style troop transports are
super inefficient in that only 20% of
their surface area can hold troops look
at that distance between the shield and
the wakandan troops that everybody
including Natasha
just traversed in 3 seconds and that
pissing match confrontation at the
shield was 100% unnecessary to the story
and the battle oh good
just what I wanted to see in this giant
Marvel movie swarms of easily killable
CGI monster clones Thanos could easily
just do the job right now but why do
that when you can reenact Braveheart
they went to the trouble of showing him
getting away Condon made but brain 'i'm
armed and in battle all we really seemed
to his fire machine-gun
I'm no war machine fan this looks hella
useful and he should just do that all
battle long up in the bedroom in order
to keep the aliens from going around and
flanking them they open the pink shield
barrier directly in front of them and
honestly it's one of the most baffling
military decisions on film since Denzel
started firing unfriendly tanks and
courage under fire why not leave cap and
you and Falcon and war machine here to
get the stragglers getting through one
at a time and send the entire rest of
the army to the back to fight the alien
foot soldiers I love how they both leap
in here punching like they somehow know
these aren't aliens with poison skin or
acid blood there are frogs here on earth
that have poison skin also safe
why didn't Fano staff his army with
aliens that had poison skin or acid
blood a bunch of whatever if the war can
withstand the energy of a star then what
can kill him it's almost like this movie
is saying all that stuff that could have
killed Thor in the other movies well
forget all that because he can take the
brunt of a star's energy because movie
really needs him to Groot finally looks
up from his video game and don't tell me
it's because he cares about Thor the
movie just needs him to get involved
here in a second teenagers did not act
moody for a long time and then suddenly
sacrifice a limb for a creepy stranger
they bumped into a couple days earlier
why not the god of axes is he so now he
in the weapon or one because he helped
create it I thought he and the hand were
one but ultimately that hammer didn't
matter and he didn't help make the
hammer either my point is these movies
give zero fucks about how the magic
space weapons wielded by God's work or
don't work
audience applause break how the fuck did
Thor know where to go once he got his
new axe why'd he go to earth instead of
Titan why not New York
Norway Thor doesn't even know what kinda
exists does he bad CGI floating head
Bruce gives me nightmares
when we faced extinction I offered a
solution genocide but random his passion
is fair to rich and poor alike you know
it'll be awesome
since the death snap doesn't
discriminate if it killed Thanos to
imagine fanno is actually deciding for
the greater good that he could even die
was such a snap but guess what you don't
have the balls for that no six stones I
could simply snap my fingers they would
all cease to exist why though why a snap
and not an okay sign or salute or middle
finger or the Shocker I feel like with
just the four stones he currently
possesses he could easily end this fight
right now the guy can currently
manipulate all the energy in the world
reality itself and let's not forget
control all life in the universe with
three of those stones don't close his
fist why you can't use the stones if he
doesn't close his fists
since fucking when moving and in why
movie honestly for a bunch of
all-powerful when they're combined
together magic space gems the Infinity
stones are super restrictive that punch
somehow doesn't kill Peter god damn that
was a punch this fucking guy how can all
these superheroes be so emotionally
wound up to make the same fatal mistake
when they hear about losing their loved
ones yeah sure it's within his character
to do this but I'm sending the movie
that this is the reason why I Thanos
escapes mantis has thrown several
hundred feet away from Thanos Spidey
reacts to this that apparently could
jump said amount of feet before mantis
lands well he finally answers the
question I have never asked about what
happens when a film character uses a
Bruce Almighty moon as a projectile and
I've got to say I should have asked this
question years ago but also everybody
survives the moon's meteor shower so you
can see the bind I'm in I know we like
him and she loves him but honestly kill
his ass and destroy the stone you idiots
the universe is at stake not once during
this battle do we you see if they're
making any real progress against these
CGI nothing's just a bunch of quickly
edited fights that act as filler until
Thanos gets here sure it's kind of cool
to see Bucky pick up rocket and perform
a 360 death ballet but in the end who
cares about the stupid army it's like
watching the Harlem Globetrotters beat
the Washington Generals while Michael
Bay coaches both teams after Thor's
where he Thunder grew taxed everyone
seeing him punch foes one of the time
here makes me wonder why it doesn't just
keep doing that first thing okay
notice you've copied my bid good thing
there's no one to fight for a few
seconds so we can have a humorous
exchange about hare Dix
[Music]
this time because Scarlet Witch was
there to destroy the mine stone if sure
he got it out of vision geez lady who do
you think you are
you're worse than cinemasins I'm not
saying I like the wakandan battle rhinos
I'm just saying they would have been
super useful in this battle vision ex
machina you should be vomiting magenta
computer code at this point but somehow
he has the strength to stand grab a
weapon and kill a fool
come on move II have just 25 percent
more consistency damn it holy is fight
between strange and Thanos is first of
all amazing as take off two sins for it
but also it's so evenly matched for so
long than it makes the group fight
against Thanos that came before it seems
silly and wimpy and underwritten so
hyoeun man shield can apparently
withstand that good to know it's not
like these stones are the most powerful
clean objects in the universe or
anything like that
arrival needed some kind of narration or
verbal confirmation if we're about to
see a reenactment of Spike Lee's old boy
here I'd only like to see one specific
scene the soul stone is the only one to
demand a sacrifice so you understand its
power but the Mayan stone is the largest
one and takes up the leader position of
all the stones in the glove honestly
should anything be able to defeat that
glove right now let alone a new axe that
we only just learned about we now
interrupt this Avengers movie to bring
you a special presentation of Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows starring
Josh Brolin is double Moore here comes
the part of the movie where the snap of
death plays a game who's gonna live and
who's gonna die and apparently it takes
its time picking and choosing because
all the dramatically relevant deaths
wait for each other so we can see them
all rather than happening at the same
time also his gun stays solid but the
new vibranium arm turns to dust
well it's distressing to see your
favorite characters wasting away don't
you just know they're all gonna be back
this kind of death scene is reminiscent
of Twilight Breaking Dawn Part 2 or the
movie stage is a free-for-all with death
galore only to show us that it was a
vision like a new chapter of final
destination with sexy vampires
it has
motional impact as an idea but
absolutely none because you know it will
be reversed there's no other way glad
you could mention this just before you
waste away in and nothing
I hear the snap loves letting people
have final words before they go geez did
Thanos move out into Camazotz or
whatever the fuck that was and a wrinkle
in time you know what that means your
spine is gonna complete the Chris QWOP
vechta in Avengers 4 woo hoo I guess
it's a good thing Nick Fury always
carries around is Captain Marvel X
mucking a pager with him wherever he
goes and that the snap waited for him to
use it so I think yes mm-hm
[Music]
the power of the Sun in the palm of my
hand
you got knocked up in order to take the
stone you must lose that which you love
I love poetry and a glass of scotch and
of course my friend Baxter here
[Music]